Si tenemos 2 grupos y en cada grupo hay 4
elementos, es decir, este es el primer grupo
de 4 y por acá tenemos el segundo grupo de 4, ya
sabemos que podemos escribir esto como 2 veces 4,
2 x 4, que es lo mismo que 4 + 4. Observa: tenemos
dos 4 por aquí, 4 más otros 4, que será igual
a... Bueno, si tenemos 4 + 4 o 2 grupos de 4, de
cualquier forma vamos a tener un total de 8 cosas,
y podemos verlo por aquí, tenemos: 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8 cosas. Lo que quiero que
hagas es pausar este video e intentes agrupar
estas mismas 8 cosas pero de manera distinta,
para que puedas representar 8 como el producto
de números enteros. Aquí representamos 8 como el
producto de 2 y 4, 2 x 4 es 8. Intenta representar
8 de varias formas distintas como el producto de
otros números enteros, es decir, agrupando
de manera distinta. Supongo que ya pausaste
el video. Intentémoslo juntos. Una cosa que
podemos hacer es ver esto en lugar de 2 grupos
de 4 como 4 grupos de 2: 1 grupo de 2, 2 grupos de
2, 3 grupos de 2 y 4 grupos de 2, entonces podemos
escribirlo como 4 x 2 que es igual a 8, y podemos
ver que esto es lo mismo que 4 veces 2: tenemos 1,
2, 3, 4 veces 2, cada grupo tiene 2 cosas, así
que podemos escribir esto como 1, 2, 3, 4 veces 2,
2 + 2 + 2 + 2 = 8. Ambos son equivalentes: 4
grupos de 2 es literalmente 4 x 2, que es lo mismo
que sumar cuatro veces 2. Observa: es lo mismo
que tenemos a la izquierda, tenemos dos 4 y los
podemos sumar, 1 y 2, mientras que aquí tenemos
4 veces 2: 1, 2, 3, 4, y sumamos cuatro veces 2.
¿De qué otra forma podemos representar 8? Bueno,
podemos verlo como 8 grupos de 1. Vamos a hacerlo:
8 grupos de 1 se van a ver así, tenemos un grupo
de 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8 grupos, así que podemos
escribir esto como 8 x 1, y una vez más esto es
igual a 8. Y si queremos escribir esto como una
suma repetida, entonces tenemos 8 unos: 1 + 1 +
1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1; veamos 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, 8 unos, 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 = 8.
Ahora tal vez estés un poco sorprendido. ¿Cuál
es la otra forma de escribir 8? Bueno, podemos
verlo como un grupo de 8, así que veámoslo de
esta forma. Tenemos un grupo de 8, tenemos
un grupo completo de 8 cosas, todos juntos,
todo el conjunto es igual a un grupo de 8, así que
podemos escribirlo como 1 x 8, 1 x 8, y 1 x 8 = 8.
Y ¿cómo podemos ver esto? Bueno, sólo tenemos un
único 8 en esta ocasión, no tenemos nada que sumar
a ese 8, por lo tanto, si queremos escribirlo de
esta forma, como lo hicimos las veces pasadas,
podemos pensarlo simplemente como un 8 y un 8 es
claramente igual a 8. Así que ahora déjame hacerte
otra pregunta: hasta ahora nos hemos enfocado en
cada uno de estos grupos, pero ¿qué tal si vemos
todo esto como 4 grupos de 8? Vamos a borrar lo
que hicimos, y ¿qué tal si vemos todo esto como 4
grupos de 8?, ¿cuántas cosas tendríamos? Déjame
ser muy claro, esta vez tenemos un grupo de 8,
dos grupos de 8, tres grupos de 8 y cuatro
grupos de 8, así que podemos ver esto como 4 x
8, 4 x 8, que será lo mismo que 8 + 8 + 8 + 8,
4 ochos. ¿Y a qué será igual esto? Te invito a
que pausas el video y encuentres la respuesta
justo ahora. Bueno, hay algunas formas en las
que podemos resolverlo, podríamos simplemente
contarlos todos o podemos ir contando de 8 en 8,
tendríamos 8, 16, 24, 32, o podemos
decir que 8 + 8 = 16 + 8 = 24 + 8 = 32,
o literalmente podremos contar todos
los triángulos que tenemos por aquí.